[Music]  today is Justin Bieber's 18th birthday  and his fans have been celebrating by  recording video messages to Justin and  posting them on YouTube there all these  messages are all over YouTube and I just  got to say I think that's it's just so  sweet  fans are so sweet take a look happy 18th  birthday Justin your fans truly do  appreciate everything you do for us this  one I wish you a very happy birthday and  I can't wait to see your girl in the  next 18 years you're an inspiration to  me Justin you smile I smile remember me  Justin Never Say Never tour I was  dragged screaming from your tour bus  [Music]  this is the happiest day of my life feel  like I've been waiting for years for  this day just waiting hiding laying low  I can see you with my heart goggles you  can see through walls  [Applause]  you